montréal la journée s'annonce éprouvante
pour les jurés au procès pour meurtre de
luca romagne tas parce qu'isabelle on va
leur présenter cet après midi la vidéo
du crime voilà inexorablement on se
dirigeait vers ce moment la couronne
avait prévenu les jurés qu'il verrait la
vidéo dans la troisième semaine on nier
et maintenant le procureur vient de leur
dire que c'est cet après midi qu'on leur
présente on la présentera à l'heure
actuelle une policière du spvm qui
témoigne nadine paoliello qui est aux
crimes technologiques c'est elle qui a
préservé la vidéo qui circulait sur
internet elle dit que l avait eu un
appel d'un policier d'ottawa qui lui
disaient que la vidéo était sur deux
s'était présente sur deux sites internet
des sites gore comme comme on l'appelle
elle n'y était jamais allé sur ces sites
mais qui présente des scènes abominable
et c'est là qu'elle a pu retracer sur
les deux sites elle faisait la même duré
dix minutes 22
elle a décrit sommairement au jury ce
qu'on y voit s'éroder scènes de
mutilation et c'est un montage alors il
ya de la musique également sur cette
petite vidéo et donc on prépare
tranquillement le jury à ces
visionnements qui sera on peut le dire
éprouvant mais je vous signale je ne
viens que quand on a choisi les jurés on
leur a demandé précisément à chacun
d'entre eux s'ils croyaient être capable
de voir ce type d'image et s'il croyait
capable pourquoi ils pensaient qu'ils
étaient capables de regarder ces images
alors toutes ces personnes ont dit qu'il
y arriverait bon on a entendu aussi un
petit peu plus tôt ce matin un employé
du comptoir postal ou manioc tu as à
faire une transaction
voilà alors le 25 mai 2012 donc au
lendemain de son crime
magno tas s'est rendu dans une pharmacie
sur queen mary tout près de nous il
habite
il a ajouté des bois postale pour faire
un envoi il s'il est retourné chez lui
et il est retourné à la pharmacie plus
tard en journée
pour poster ces colis morbide on le sait
il a posté des parties du corps de deux
lignes jaunes à ottawa des partis
politiques ainsi qu'à vancouver dans des
écoles primaires
alors on a vu les images des caméras de
surveillance qui vous colle qui montrait
manioc taille y aller et en sortir de
cette pharmacie c'est là où on en est
justice de montréal merci beaucoup je
vous en prie on voit revoir